moi je trouve ça un peu hypocrite parce
que le dire c'est une chose après des
journalistes par exemple ne le disent
pas en l'occurrence par exemple la
Salamé et j'ai le boulot qui vont faire
le débat ce soir ils ne le disent pas
mais on sait tous très bien autour de
cette table qui ne vont pas voter pour
Marine Le Pen on le sait donc finalement
l'influence le fait de le dire ça
influence pas plus que ça au contraire
je pense que ne pas le dire parfois ça
permet d'avancer à visage masqué et
finalement de faire passer des messages
sans que on puisse nous reprocher que on
est parti pris et donc
ils n'ont jamais exprimé clairement non
mais est-ce que tu pèses
c'est une évidence
mais à travers certaines questions
dirigées et ben ils vont pouvoir donner
quelque part leur point de vue aussi
alors c'est juste que ce n'est pas
direct donc c'est là c'est j'arrête pas
de dire que je kiffe Jean la salle par
exemple tu fais tout le monde sérieux
mais jamais à un moment donné vous êtes
engagé moi je serai incapable de savoir
pour qui enfin bon maintenant oui mais
je serai capable de savoir pour qui vous
votez quand il y a 9 candidats sur le
terrain je suis désolé et vous êtes vous
êtes le chef d'orchestre de cette
émission heureusement je dirais parce
que ce sera un vrai problème et pour la
chaîne sur la com donc à un moment donné
il faut de la neutralité mais est-ce que
Léa Salamé selon toi elle est neutre
c'est ton idée c'est ton idée à un
moment donné on est en train de parler
je pense qu'on est tous d'accord vous
prenez vous que Delphine et Bernard et
ben c'était PMU comprenez-vous cette
décision il y a eu un moment donné de la
part excusez-moi mais il y a eu un
moment donné de la part de Delphine
clairement mais elle fait pas mais elle
a exprimé son ami tu es obligé hier
j'étais obligé
contre Valérie minime qui disait Bernard
Montiel n'était pas décompté j'étais
obligé de lui dire s'il est décompté
[Rires]
donc aujourd'hui Bernard j'ai appris que
vous étiez décompté c'est bien la
première fois qu'on vous décompte
de les avancer non mais moi je comprends
pas la décision de les évincer puisque à
partir du moment où ils sont gagnés
donc on a pas besoin de de les
faire-part hier Cyril par exemple vous
disiez que vous étiez vous trouviez que
c'était normal que Mourad qui quitte les
grosses têtes pas les grosses têtes les
grands gars
mais moi je trouve que dans tous les cas
de figure Delphine Mourad Bernard ils
n'ont pas à quitté la tête il faut
simplement
Le Pen pour démarrer comme la fée Mourad
et faire un discours voilà pendant
pendant 15 minutes Mourad c'est son
choix il a il a voilà il a le droit de
le faire après
même Mourad la compris Raquel Garrido
elle le sait très bien je l'ai tous les
jours elle me dit voilà je comprends que
je suis pas là en ce moment sur les
émissions c'est normal euh Gilles Verdez
vous je suis pas d'accord avec vous
Cyril pour moi
allez on oublie tout ça allez
entièrement d'accord avec vous d'accord
pour moi pour moi Delphine et Bernard
dans cette campagne politique sont deux
militants Delphine à sa manière appelant
à voter Marine Le Pen pour éliminer
ma phrase est-ce que tu peux me trouver
une seule séquence ou j'ai dit voter
Marine Le Pen ah oui oui non non non
j'ai fait un argumentaire j'ai expliqué
ce qui me plaisait ce qui ne me plaisait
pas dans ce qu'on a vécu point final non
trouve-moi la phrase j'en ai marre non
non il y avait Géraldine qui m'a dit oui
mais alors voilà donc tu vas te Marine
Le Pen voilà
il a dit de ma bouche ce n'est jamais le
sorti et j'aimerais juste parce qu'on
parlait juste d'hypocrisie j'aimerais
rebondir sur ce qu'a dit Valérie est-ce
qu'on a les images de ce qui s'est passé
hier juste on a des images j'appelle
non juste pour savoir
[Rires]
de Delphine qui a dit hier je veux que
Marine Le Pen soit la maman
donc pourquoi est-ce qu'elle est pas
viré donc voilà oui parce que je
répondais à Cyril parce que Cyril
trouver que c'était normal qu'on vire
mourra donc je disais si il trouve
normal qu'on vire Mora il faut c'est
normal qu'on devient non alors est-ce
que je ne suis pas parce que je ne veux
pas qu'on te vire que je veux qu'on te
décompte d'accord
on l'a pas vu s'exprimer au meeting
d'Emmanuel Macron Delphine on l'a jamais
vu s'exprimer dans un dans aucun autre
dans un carneting non plus je suis
désolé là là les mecs c'est deux c'est
c'est c'est pas du tout le même cas
Géraldine moi je trouve que cette règle
c'est peut-être la règle mais je trouve
c'est complètement hypocrite en fait
déjà Bernard ok c'est l'ami de Macron
c'est l'ami de Brigitte Macron mais il
nous a jamais dit pour qu'il voter alors
on peut s'en douter mais à partir de ce
moment-là
tu vois le projet là
moi j'ai dîné avec François Hollande
est-ce que j'ai est-ce que j'ai voté
pour Hidalgo j'ai dîner
est-ce que j'ai non mais est-ce que j'ai
voté pour Pécresse je veux dire c'est
que oui mais c'est compliqué parce qu'on
est on est positionné ici on donne nos
avis voilà je trouve que c'est ridicule
comme l'a dit Hugo tout à l'heure très
justement BFM avait la réputation d'être
plutôt macroniste Zemmour a lancé a été
une rampe de lancement c'est News a été
une rampe de lancement pour Zemmour
France Inter à la réputation d'être
plutôt de gauche donc arrêtons
l'hypocrisie arrêtons de prendre les
gens pour des débiles moi je trouve et
je ne suis pas d'accord avec Delphine
par rapport à son opinion politique mais
je trouve qu'elle a eu beaucoup et je le
redis encore c'est un cas rarissime ça
n'existe pas Delphine aujourd'hui dans
la dans la dans le dans le monde
médiatique aujourd'hui il y a pas une
personne de la notoriété de la jeunesse
de Delphine qui a dit moi je vote pour
ma pour Marine Le Pen encore mes propos
puisque je ne l'ai jamais dit mais
effectivement mais globalement pardon
tous les gens tous les gens disent
il vote à gauche
les artistes en vote à gauche donc ils
sont cool quand ceux qui ont dit on vote
pour Sarko ils ont été carrément
placardisés c'est la jurisprudence
modèle donc moi je trouve excuse-moi moi
je trouve que c'est injuste parce que
quelque part on dit à 32 % des gens qui
ont voté pour des l'extrême droite en
gros vous avez pas droit de le dire
parce que finalement voilà vous donc
c'est très hypocrite donc moi à la
raison de dire
concrètement moi ça me fait très bizarre
d'être là en tant qu'invité pourquoi
donc là je suis puni pourquoi et je suis
mis je suis mise au placard parce que
quoi j'étais trop courageuse j'étais
trop authentique j'ai dit ce que je
pensais pourquoi parce que j'ai fait mon
travail de chroniqueurs on sait très
bien qu'ici le but c'est de donner notre
avis sur la télé réalité sur des fêtes
société et en ce moment sur de la
politique donc en fait j'ai juste bien
fait mon job j'ai et sur la chicha aussi
donc en fait j'ai juste bien fait mon
job et là voilà on me met au placard
pourquoi parce que j'ai utilisé mon
droit de liberté de penser et de
m'exprimer et d'ailleurs à ce propos
donc du coup je devais faire toute la
semaine vous le savez on en a parlé
ensemble donc concrètement je perds des
émissions donc je perds de l'argent et
donc c'est le prix ça ce que je perds
c'est le prix de la liberté donc
aujourd'hui en France la liberté c'est
quoi comme mot liberté égalité
aujourd'hui je suis sanctionné je perds
de l'argent par rapport à ça c'est le
prix de la liberté et je vais le redire
pour que tout le monde le comprenne on a
fait beaucoup de blagues sur Bernard
porte-parole du gouvernement et ça pas
pendant le la période présidentielle ça
fait longtemps qu'on en parle donc
quelque part tu es connoté moi j'ai
jamais parlé de présidentielle de
politique mais là j'en parle parce que
c'est le moment voilà et dans trois
jours j'en parlerai plus parce que voilà
c'est fini et d'ailleurs à partir de ce
soir je n'en parle plus ce que je veux
dire c'est que moi je ne suis pas
porte-parole du gouvernement donc pas
d'Emmanuel Macron donc ça tout le monde
l'a compris je ne suis pas non plus
porte-parole de Marine Le Pen je suis
juste une porte-parole des Français qui
ont été mécontents et qui sont déçus de
ce quinquennat c'est tout c'est tout
voilà c'est c'est
globalement pour ces idées et en gros on
leur dit mais en fait si vous votez pour
ses idées vous pouvez pas apparaître
dans les médias parce que finalement ça
pue en fait parce que vous êtes vous
êtes soupçonné de racisme et tout ça non
moi je pense que ça c'est un vrai
problème il faut combattre les vidéos
contre les personnes et étaient racistes
franchement je la connais bien je pense
qu'on serait pas aussi amis et on serait
pas dans l'émission vous savez on a des
valeurs ici dans l'émission qui sont
claires tous ensemble ici on le sait
donc voilà donc je pense que Delphine
voilà elle serait pas dans l'émission je
pense que Delphine t'a voulu être le
porte-parole d'une certaine partie de la
population et les régions en fait et que
et que et que derrière voilà tu t'en es
mordu les doigts je pense que c'est ça
aussi et Gilles je pense tu es d'accord
avec moi mais c'est vrai que si Delphine
était raciste on allait tous les deux on
se connaît bien on est on est on est
même valeur on discute très souvent avec
Delphine si elle avait des idées
racistes ou voilà autre ou
franchement on sera pas ami avec elle
c'est pas ça le mais simplement ce mot
parce que c'est la première fois de ma
vie qu'on me qu'on me dit ça
j'ai pas besoin là qu'on me défende je
veux juste vous expliquer que on est sur
un plateau où on a de la chance de
pouvoir donner
de dire ce qu'on pense et on a la parole
donc moi quand j'entends des trucs et
que je glande des informations dans les
régions sur les séances dédicaces et
tout ça ben là j'ai la chance Siri me
donne la chance de parler et donc je
m'exprime et il y a juste un point parce
que je sais maintenant quel est le point
qui a fait basculer c'est quand j'ai
parlé de maman des Français et je vais
vous leur expliquer pourquoi est-ce que
j'ai dit ça il savait pu être n'importe
quel autre femme d'ailleurs Valérie
Pécresse si elle s'en était mieux sortie
j'aurais dit pourquoi pas le côté
maternel le côté les femmes qui ont des
couilles on aime ça et on sait que les
femmes qui ont des couilles
plus loin elles vont beaucoup que
certains hommes et pourquoi est-ce que
j'ai dit par exemple maman des Français
parce que ça m'a fait penser par exemple
à Angela Merkel on dit Mutti dernière
en Israël aussi c'était c'était la maman
de l'islaine c'est la même chose c'est
pour ça en fait que j'ai que j'ai
utilisé cette rhétorique c'est pas pour
autant que ça m'a fait basculer dans les
soutiens voilà je suis juste une
française qui a été déçue et je pense
qu'il y a beaucoup beaucoup de personnes
qui sont derrière moi alors
Bernard Tabu retard mon Bernard
[Applaudissements]
ce que tu es triste voilà d'être pas du
tout non c'est vrai pas du tout je
trouve ça très curieux d'être condamné à
cause de ses amitiés moi je suis ami
avec les Macron depuis fort longtemps
bien avant les présidentielles pardon
vous faites perdre du temps
donc je vous dis je suis condamné
simplement parce que je suis ami avec
eux ce sont des amis que j'adore que
j'aime profondément et que je respecte
maintenant dans cette émission je n'ai
jamais fait du prosélytisme j'ai jamais
dit voté pour un tel ou voter pour elle
et des fois et parfois je le dis et il a
été dur il a été dur sur des décisions
il a dit ok
vous savez qu'on peut avoir des amis et
ne pas toujours être d'accord et souvent
j'ai été contre des décisions
non mais c'est étonnant parce que c'est
vrai que tous ici on s'exprime très
librement et c'est bien moi je disais
encore tout à l'heure Adelphine que
j'aime beaucoup je la respecte
totalement Delphine qui vote pour qui tu
veux comme je dis à tous les Français
votez pour qui vous voulez jamais je me
fâcherai pour ça vous voyez même dans ma
famille il y a des gens qui votent très
différemment et j'aime ma famille et
jamais frère voilà donc c'est pas le
problème mes frères oui j'étais oui
j'étais frères on en parle de notre
choix vous faites perdre du temps avec
truc bordel tu parles c'est bien tu as
des frères
je savais pas que tu avais des frères
mon tien
il a rien compris si j'ai compris
est-ce que c'est politique ça c'est
trois frères et une religion pour moi
c'est politique on n'est pas tous
d'accord voilà donc je répète être
condamné parce qu'on est amis avec des
personnes c'est triste je suis très fier
d'être leur ami j'espère être un peu
leur ami quand on reste je le rappelle
dans cette émission je n'ai jamais fait
de prosélytisme je n'ai jamais dit que
je voté pour j'ai pas dit pour qu'ils
votait évidemment on s'en doute mais
peut-être que peut-être que c'est pas ça
non je te crois pas non tu me crois pas
tu m'as appelé le porte-parole pendant 6
mois au gouvernement donc si les relis
tu vas reprendre 5 ans inch'Allah
[Rires]
stop
moi je suis pas pour qu'on les écarte
mais je trouve que là quand même il y a
une certaine hypocrisie mon cher Bernard
dans vos propres
tout tu nous fais chier en permanence
vous étiez vous étiez quand même un
meeting sans vous cacher d'Emmanuel
Macron et alors tu peux être longue
de Mélenchon que j'aime beaucoup comme
je peux aller à meeting normal
la chaîne est donc sans doute Cyril
prennent la décision que vous ne soyez
pas là c'est qu'il y a une raison quand
même vous êtes des soutiens n'ont pas
indéfectible mais réel et affiché de
chacun des deux candidats c'est pour ça
que moi je suis pour que vous restiez
parce que ça s'équilibre mais n'allez
pas nous dire maintenant que vous ne
soutenez pas que vous n'allez pas voter
vous pour marine ou alors je comprends
plus rien pourquoi et donc le courage de
parler du sujet dont on parle en fait
donne ton opinion et puis donner tout ce
que c'est opinions au lieu de ne rien
voter au premier tour j'ai pas de
problème avec ça je pas comme cantonne
seulement aux animaux à la chasse à
l'anti-chasse et tout machin je me suis
dit tiens bah pourquoi pas j'ai aussi la
légitimité de m'exprimer sur des sujets
qui ne touchent pas que les animaux par
exemple la politique et j'ai mis autant
de coeur à défendre ce que j'ai entendu
que par exemple des sujets pour les
animaux ou des sujets contre le vaccin
j'ai aussi mis mon cœur à ce moment-là
mais pourquoi est-ce que vous vous ne le
faites pas parce que sinon à ce
moment-là il y a plus personne autour de
la table je vous le dis puisse
s'exprimer sur leur vote de dimanche
prochain par exemple et c'est le but de
cette émission
c'est absolument pas dîner c'est de
donner ses idées politiques
je ne te compare pas avec Bernard parce
que Bernard en l'occurrence il n'a
jamais tenu des propos il s'est jamais
engagé ouvertement je suis une victime
finalement j'aimerais juste te dire je
condamne Cyril je condamne comme tout le
monde autour de la table toutes les
violences qui a pu y avoir sur les
réseaux sociaux contre Delphine bien
évidemment non ce que je veux juste te
dire c'est que à un moment donné à un
moment donné d'ailleurs la preuve Marine
Le Pen a repris le terme maman en disant
mère des Français maintenant mais je
veux dire un monde tu es chroniqueur ou
tu es expert dans ton domaine et tu
donnes ton avis devant des
téléspectateurs qui te regarde quel est
mon domaine en l'occurrence tu vois moi
je suis plus gêné par ça pour moi un
journaliste un animateur un chroniqueur
un expert n'a pas à donner ses origines
politiques et pas parler donc j'étais
Miss j'aime les animaux donc j'ai le
droit de parler des Miss de
l'environnement et des animaux et du
guitariste
aujourd'hui donc c'est bien il y a bien
une raison pour ça c'est parce que ça ne
regarde que la personne
sans manquer de respect du tout ni à
Bernard Delphine je pense que l'impact
de d'un discours d'un chroniqueur va pas
non plus bouleverser la campagne donc je
pense qu'il faut redescendre un petit
peu et finalement quand on dit
clairement il y a un laisse-moi jouer
si tu si tu ne dis pas clairement pour
qui tu vas tu pars des dizaines de
billets tu en donnes l'idée donc
finalement on le fait c'est notre rôle
aussi quand on parle à un moment de la
campagne pendant des semaines autour de
cette table on dit des choses on dit des
choses on dit pas je vais voter pour
mais on laisse imaginer un certain
nombre de d'indices qui permettent de
comprendre pour qui on va voter et nos
idées en tout cas et nos convictions oui
il y a des influenceuses donc qui ne
sont pas à la télé mais qui ont des
millions de personnes qui font des
stories en disant je vote bon par
exemple pour pour Emmanuel Macron mais
elle elle ne sont pas censurées par
exemple et on sait que au cumul deux
personnes à qui je pense Nabilla et
Maëva gaynam elles ont à L2 10 millions
de personnes et les deux ont dit ok on
vote pour Macron donc avec une story qui
24 heures donc au niveau du temps de
parole ou du décompte ils sont c'est
beaucoup plus que moi quand je dis pas
encore des règles sur les réseaux
sociaux
aujourd'hui on sait que les réseaux
sociaux les réseaux sociaux c'est le
nouveau média est en train de surpasser
la télé alors pourquoi est-ce qu'on nous
bride tellement à la télé et on laisse
souffert sur les réseaux sociaux c'est
pas juste elle elle gagnera l'argent sur
les réseaux sociaux moi aussi en tant
qu'influenceuse mais en partie aussi ici
donc je suis handicapée à cause de ça
par exemple c'est pas c'est pas normal
Daniel alors moi je comprends cette
décision parce que on le voit bien là en
rigolant avec Bernard la difficulté
qu'aurait les missions à décompter les
temps de parole c'est très compliqué ça
va être quelques jours et je crois qu'il
faut assumer tu as été hyper courageuse
on l'a tous dit mais hier par exemple
devant un million 800 000 personnes tu
as dénoncé le scandale mackenza avec des
mots très violents est-ce que c'est je
suis désolé tu peux vraiment orienter
les gens contre Emmanuel Macron il faut
l'assumer
je ne le reproche absolument pas tu as
le droit de dire ce que tu veux mais il
faut pas assumer il comprend que pour
les trois quatre derniers jours c'est
trop de gens avec ce que tu as dit déjà
sur Marine Le Pen et contre manuel
Macron ça n'est pas possible c'est trop
c'est dans le règlement actuel c'est
trop il faut peut-être le changer la
différence entre entre Bernard et
Delphine dont je salue le courage parce
qu'elle pensait elle s'est livrée avec
le cœur et je trouve ça très fort
Bernard a aucun moment je l'ai entendu
défends le bilan d'Emmanuel Macron
expliquer combien le président était
formidable qu'il allait évidemment voté
pour lui et qu'il y avait un choix qui
se posait et que pour lui le choix était
clair il allait faire le choix de de
Macron je n'ai jamais entendu Bernard et
la seule blague qu'on avait fait sur le
plateau c'est vous qui l'avez fait
pendant 6 mois c'est c'est le
porte-parole en revanche
c'est mieux vous êtes un clown comme
dirait ma mère la mère de Daniel et le
clown par contre Delphine depuis 3 jours
à un discours qui a un discours pour moi
qui a un discours militant ou à la
défendu une position avec une prise de
position sur le vaccin sur les gilets
jaunes
tout ce qui fait le sel du programme
politique de Spa finir de Madame Le Pen
et je suis désolé dans le discours de
Delphine il y avait effectivement un
engagement politique clair et net que je
n'ai jamais dit que non mais juste
là là je trouve sincèrement que ce que
vous avez dit ce que vous avez dit sur
la ligne d'accord avec moi sur ce que je
veux dire sur Daniel et Benjamin là je
trouve que vous êtes s'il vous plaît je
trouve que vous êtes complètement à côté
de la plaque excusez-moi de vous dire ça
Delphine elle parle de fait d'actualité
on est d'accord
à monter sur le créneau sur les vaccins
bien sûr on va pas me décompter parce
que je j'aime exactement quand elle
parle des gilets jaunes quand elle parle
des gilets jaunes aussi c'est c'est
d'actualité on en a parlé maintenant de
toi dans cette émission quand elle parle
de l'affaire McKinsey on l'a pas traité
dans cette émission je vais vous dire
pourquoi on ne l'a pas traitée on
trouvait que c'était extrêmement
technique voilà on trouvait voilà que
les le le sujet était extrêmement
technique que voilà que on trouvait pas
sa populaire en émission extrêmement
populaire on parle de sujet voilà qui
concerne tout le monde et retrouver
voilà que même les cabinets de conseils
moi personnellement je savais même pas
que ça existait donc forcément voilà on
s'est dit que c'était pas un sujet pour
TPMP mais elle a évoqué le sujet hier
comme elle a évoqué plusieurs sujets
d'actualité Guillaume après il faut
quand même dire la vérité même si
aujourd'hui il y a énormément de
Français qui votent pour Marine Le Pen
il faut les respecter ça choque plus
l'opinion aujourd'hui c'est vrai d'avoir
quelqu'un qui se qui qui en tout cas qui
soutient ou qui témoigne de sa sympathie
publiquement pour Marine Le Pen qui
Emmanuel Macron il y a une tribune il y
a pas longtemps ça choque en fait bah si
je suis te dire il y a un tribu il y a
pas longtemps
je vais trahir je vais trahir un petit
secret de la physique excuse-moi mais
Delphine elle a eu énormément
de je vous dis de coup de pression comme
on dit voilà voilà d'employeur de trucs
ça c'est pas normal
je le disais
mais Delphine il y a des gens qui l'ont
dit attention on va enlever tel contrat
Attention
avec y compris les animateurs télé qui
se sont engagés à voter Macron y compris
des animateurs de divertissement qui
n'ont rien à voir avec la politique je
les vois toujours à l'antenne donc ça il
faut arrêter mais c'est ce que les gens
ne supportent pas les donneurs de leçon
les gens ne veulent plus les gens c'est
pas qu'on s'engage en politique c'est
qu'on dise je vote Le Pen parce qu'ils
choque l'opinion en tout cas ça c'est
vrai c'est sûr et là tu as pas entendu
la même polémique mais
ça c'est pas dit je vote Le Pen j'ai
j'ai parlé de bienveillance en fait pour
contrebalancer le côté diabolique que
tout le monde veut la diaboliser donc je
la fais je voilà j'ai mis bienveillance
pour qu'elle soit une candidate normale
comparé un candidat apparemment normal
bon même si c'est le président sortant
et du coup il a il a plus de panache et
tout forcément j'aimerais juste que les
gens votent de manière égale et se
disent ok je peux faire ça ou je peux
faire ça parce que forcément si la
pression et la masse dit ok on dit
abolisse ce côté bah les gens comme ça
moi j'ai juste dit ok la bienveillance
pour contrebalancer ce que les médias
parce que les médias ils sont ils sont
sous le diabolise
par exemple je le dis je l'ai toujours
dit ici et il y a on parle de programme
quand Marine Le Pen dit qu'elle va être
d'ailleurs elle est revenue là-dessus
elle va interdire le port du voile en
France je l'ai toujours dit que ça me
dérangeait voilà ça c'est un point du
programme qui me dérange énormément il y
a des voilà et ça n'a pas réussi voilà
exactement
ça me dérange mais on peut avoir un
débat sur les programmes voilà
maintenant c'est vrai que derrière
Delphine soit en voilà se prennent des
des coups de pressions à droite à gauche
concernant ces contrats etc c'est un
petit peu
on le sait tous les deux on a vu on a vu
les programmes de chacun voilà on sait
que on sait que voilà il y a plein de
choses qui nous dérange dans le
programme de un Marine Le Pen on l'a dit
ici on met on impose aux gens d'avoir
honte en fait on n'a pas avoir honte de
voter pour Marine Le Pen si on a envie
de voter pour Marino
on a reçu tous les candidats de la même
façon on sait très bien voilà que voilà
on a reçu Eric Zemmour on a la même
façon que Jean-Luc Mélenchon que Marine
Le Pen que Valérie Pécresse on essaie
d'être le plus juste possible pour
essayer de de se cantonner au programme
et voilà il ne pas dire quand un homme
politique ici on va déjà l'attaquer sur
son truc et on va arriver avec un a
priori négatif on essaie d'être le plus
le plus juste possible et je pense que
c'est ça qui a plu aussi aux Français
qui les ont pu les voir dans voilà dans
un autre contexte c'est vrai Bernard et
toi aujourd'hui tu écarté tu le
comprends tout à fait mais voilà c'est
vrai que tu n'as jamais dit je vote
Emmanuel Macron a voté pour Emmanuel
Macron
élitine je le redis dans cette émission
effectivement moi enfin vous parliez du
voile du voile elle veut mettre des
amandes aux femmes voilées ce qui est
important voilà ça c'est quand même
important de le rappeler et puis par
rapport à tous les enjeux qui arrivent
maintenant internationaux c'est vrai que
c'est grave qui a-t-on envie de voir je
dis pas un tel ou un tel qui a-t-on
envie de voir à la tête du pays face à
un Poutine bon c'est que Madame Le Pen
veut en faire un allié après l'Ukraine
bon voilà il y a on se pose quand même
plein de questions tout ça là voilà
profondément dans le fait qu'il soit
écarté c'est que je trouve que vous
serrez l'émission est victime du
pluralisme d'opinion qu'elle a toujours
incarné et de la volonté que tout le
monde s'exprime avant les élections sur
tous les sujets toutes les avions vous
avez vu la volonté ici d'accueillir des
gens de diverses opinions et je trouve
que c'est pas bien c'est pour ça que je
suis pour qu'il reste c'est pas bien que
des gens qui donnent leur opinion qui se
sont exprimés sur des sujets de société
ici on a eu de tout on a eu des gens
pour et contre le vaccin pourrait
contrôler pourraient contre tout et ça
vous l'avez incarné et là on vous le
reproche en les écartant ça moi c'est
pour ça que c'est pour ça que je trouve
que la décision de la chaîne n'est pas
dans la chaîne est normalement alors la
décision de les écarter une décision
c'est une règle il y a des règles c'est
une journée
c'est très important de le préciser
l'arcom ne peut pas intégrer ou
s'infiltrer dans une ligne éditorial de
l'émission C'est pas ils ont simplement
rappelé qu'il y avait un temps de parler
à respecter c'est tout et c'est donc une
décision de la chaîne qui nous a prié de
nous écarter pour le moment etc et c'est
normal on le comprend très bien voilà
alors c'est vrai que voilà moi au départ
il y a Éric Zemmour on l'a dit qui
faisait énormément le buzz on avait on
parlait énormément d'Éric Zemmour après
il faisait moins le buzz on en parlait
pour le plus du tout après c'est Valérie
Pécresse qui demandait de l'argent
forcément on a parlé de Valérie Pécresse
un moment
on a parlé énormément de Mélenchon donc
c'est vrai que voilà nous on traite la
qualité et on traite ceux qui font et
d'ailleurs voilà et c'est ce qu'on fait
ce soir